La démission du général De Gaulle
fait la une des journaux du monde.
De toutes les capitales étrangères
sont parvenues des messages de sympathie.
Tout d'abord, le président Nixon
a adressé une lettre au général De Gaulle.
Nous, aux États-Unis, n'oublierons pas
ce que vous avez fait pour la France,
aussi bien à l'intérieur du pays,
que dans le domaine
de la politique étrangère.
Réaction aussi du Ministre
Ouest-allemand des Affaires étrangères.
La défaite
du général De Gaulle au référendum
n'est pas seulement importante
pour la politique intérieure française,
elle l'est aussi
pour la politique européenne.
En Afrique aussi,
les réactions sont nombreuses.
Le président de la République
du Sénégal, M. Senghor,
a adressé
un télégramme au Général De Gaulle
dans lequel il exprime
sa reconnaissance et celle du Sénégal
à l'égard de l'homme
grâce auquel la décolonisation
s'est déroulée dans l'honneur et l'amitié.
La vie politique va
prendre une tout autre dimension.
Nous allons sortir
du domaine de l'histoire.
d'une période politique
qui a été vécue avec un homme
d'une portée absolument exceptionnelle.
Et nous allons rentrer,
maintenant, dans le domaine du commun.
Avril 1969,
Colombey-les-Deux-Églises.
Ultime étape.
Acte final d'une vie exceptionnelle.
Maintenant, après son échec
au référendum et sa brutale démission,
Charles de Gaulle se
retire dans une solitude orgueilleuse
à La Boisserie, sa demeure familiale.
Ici, il va lutter contre le temps
pour écrire ses mémoires d'espoir,
livrer ses ultimes pensées.
Ces journées consacrées à l'écriture
seront seulement interrompues
par trois promenades
méditatives à heure fixe,
dans le silence du parc.
Cet homme,
au crépuscule de sa vie,
rentre dans la légende
au terme d'une existence
faite de combats et de bruits,
portée par la certitude
qu'il avait un destin
et qu'il l'a accompli.
Tout a commencé à Lille,
le 22 novembre 1890,
car pour respecter
une tradition familiale,
les enfants devaient voir
le jour auprès de leur grand-mère.
Charles grandit entre
trois frères et une sœur.
Pour ses parents, la France
éternelle transcende la République.
L'argent est méprisable
par rapport aux valeurs de l'esprit
et le patriotisme est non négociable.
On lit Peggy,
Bergson,
Maurras,
Barrès et d'autres.
Je savais que j'avais un destin.
Mes parents m'ont montré la route.
Mon père,
un homme de grande culture,
m'a fait comprendre
l'histoire et ses tumultes.
Ma mère portait à la patrie
une passion intransigeante,
à l'égal de sa piété religieuse.
Elle m'a transmis le goût
du risque et de l'abnégation.
Bien que turbulent
et d'un caractère difficile,
le jeune Charles
est imprégné de ces principes moraux.
C'est un lecteur passionné,
d'Adolphe Thiers à Jules Verne.
Sa sœur raconte
que dans leurs jeux d'enfants,
son frère voulait
toujours être roi de France.
Chez le jeune Charles,
l'ambition est précoce.
À 15 ans,
il a imaginé
qu'un jour il sauverait la France.
Il écrira : "La France
s'est faite à coups d'épée."
C'est donc dans l'armée qu'il pense
être le mieux placé pour servir son pays.
À 19 ans,
il est reçu au concours de Saint-Cyr.
Mais il est allergique à la routine
de la vie de la caserne et aux corvées.
En raison de sa forte
personnalité et de sa haute silhouette,
il est déjà surnommé le connétable.
Il impressionne par
sa culture et l'ambition de ses projets.
En 1912,
lorsqu'il sort 13ème de
sa promotion de Saint-Cyr,
les commentaires
de ses supérieurs sont élogieux.
A beaucoup
de moyens, de l'énergie,
du zèle, de l'enthousiasme,
du commandement et de la décision.
Alors qu'il peut accéder à
des unités plus prestigieuses,
il choisit curieusement
d'intégrer le 33ème régiment d'infanterie,
cantonné à Arras.
Le colonel qui commande ce régiment,
un certain Philippe Pétain, a 56 ans.
Son non-conformisme,
son caractère abrupt
irritent la hiérarchie militaire.
Les deux hommes s'apprécient
et tissent des liens de complicité.
Leur relation prend
même des tournures plus privées.
Plus tard, De Gaulle fera
cette confidence à un journaliste.
Il aimait les femmes
comme on les aime à 50 ans,
et je les méprisais
comme on les méprise à 20 ans,
c'est-à-dire que
nous en parlions tout le temps.
La Grande Guerre va révéler Pétain,
promu général de brigade puis maréchal.
En novembre 1918,
Il deviendra pour tout
le pays, le héros de Verdun.
La Grande Guerre a permis à
Philippe Pétain de rencontrer la gloire.
Elle ne fut pour moi
que frustration, impatience et colère.
Je voulais me battre
et je n'étais qu'un soldat inutile.
La pire des situations.
En effet,
dès le début de la guerre,
le jeune lieutenant De Gaulle
s'est lancé dans le combat avec fougue.
Trois blessures ne
l'empêchent pas de repartir au front.
Finalement, il est fait prisonnier.
Il multiplie les tentatives d'évasion.
Il est enfermé au fort d'Ingolstadt,
réservé aux récidivistes,
et reste 32 mois à
se morfondre dans le silence des prisons.
Il noircit des carnets où il suit
de loin l'évolution des combats.
Il déverse sa colère
contre la hiérarchie,
fulmine contre le pape
qui a des penchants pour l'ennemi.
Il qualifie le gouvernement d'épiciers.
Dans une lettre adressée à sa mère,
il décrit sa situation de captif,
comme un lamentable exil.
Libéré après l'armistice,
il demande
immédiatement à partir en mission
pour soutenir les Polonais
qui se battent contre les Soviétiques.
Instructeur,
le capitaine de Gaulle est chargé
de la formation des officiers
puis conseiller militaire.
Il ne se sent plus
un soldat inutile et invisible.
En effet,
lors de son retour à Paris,
le jeune capitaine
devient professeur à Saint-Cyr.
Souvent glacial,
distant ou gouailleur,
il subjugue son auditoire
et inspire des caricatures.
Il est reçu à l'école de guerre,
mais il reste peu
malléable, souvent critique.
Un tel état d'esprit irrite.
De plus
dans son premier livre,
La Discorde chez l'ennemi,
il conteste le haut commandement
et le rôle des militaires.
Ses écrits le privent
d'une mention très bien.
L'encadrement commande,
officier cultivé et sérieux,
brillant et doué,
gâte malheureusement
d'incontestables qualités
par son assurance
excessive et son attitude de roi en exil.
Roi en exil,
ces idiots de l'école de guerre.
L'autorité ne va pas sans le prestige,
et le prestige sans l'éloignement.
J'avais décidé de ne
revenir dans cette sale boîte
qu'en qualité de commandant de l'école.
En 1920,
la trentaine passée,
il songe à fonder une famille.
Selon les habitudes
du milieu et de l'époque,
une rencontre est arrangée.
Elle est organisée
en secret par la famille Vendroux.
Leur première sortie
est au Grand Palais,
au Salon d'automne,
pour voir l'œuvre de Kees Van Dongen.
La femme en bleu.
Charles est séduit par
le charme d'Yvonne Vendroux.
Ils se plaisent.
Ils se marient le 7 avril 1921.
Elle a 20 ans et elle sera
à ses côtés pendant 50 ans.
Elle est sa lumière et son ombre.
"Pour vous, Yvonne,
sans qui rien ne se serait fait",
écrira De Gaulle quand
il lui adressera ses Mémoires d'espoir.
La discrète Yvonne, tante Yvonne,
comme la surnomment les Français,
cultive la simplicité
et se tient à bonne distance.
Bien que présente sur
de nombreuses photos et films,
elle ne donne jamais aucun entretien.
Le grand public ne
connaît pas le son de sa voix.
Paradoxalement, elle sera
l'une des premières dames
à véritablement jouer un rôle médiatique.
En arrivant à l'Elysée, elle s'exclame.
"Désormais,
il va nous falloir vivre en meublé".
Elle n'aime pas le lieu et dira
au président des États-Unis Eisenhower,
"tout le monde y est chez soi, sauf nous".
Pendant dix ans,
Yvonne de Gaulle
mène au palais de l'Élysée
un train de vie simple et mesuré.
Elle met un point d'honneur
à régler les factures privées.
Elle incarne
une forme d'ordre moral.
Cependant,
à propos de la pilule,
lorsque Charles de Gaulle
s'indigne à l'idée
qu'on puisse rembourser la bagatelle,
sa femme intervient pour le convaincre
de l'importance de la loi Neuwirth
qui autorise ce contraceptif.
Pour mieux comprendre
la personnalité d'Yvonne de Gaulle,
il faut rappeler
le drame qui a frappé le couple.
Anne, la benjamine de la famille,
est porteuse d'une trisomie 21.
Avec cette naissance,
la vie d'Yvonne et
de Charles est bouleversée.
Accompagnés de
leurs deux autres enfants,
Philippe et Élisabeth,
ils vont veiller sur Anne avec amour.
La famille traversera
les épreuves de la guerre
avec cette déchirante responsabilité.
Charles de Gaulle manifeste
une tendresse infinie pour la fillette.
Pour la protéger de
l'indiscrétion du public,
la famille s'est installée en 1934,
à Colombey-les-Deux-Églises,
dans une demeure entourée de
hauts murs qu'ils dénomment La Boisserie.
C'est là qu'en 1948,
Anne meurt d'une pneumonie
dans les bras de son père.
Elle venait d'avoir 20 ans.
Le jour de ses obsèques,
il chuchote à l'oreille d'Yvonne.
"Maintenant, elle est comme les autres".
Cet enfant infiniment délicat
a contribué à forger
la personnalité de Charles de Gaulle.
Il confie,
"Anne était aussi une grâce".
"Elle m'a aidé à dépasser
tous les échecs et tous les hommes",
"à voir plus haut".
En dépit de la vie mouvementée
de De Gaulle et de la fragilité d'Anne,
la famille restera toujours unie.
Ainsi, en 1929,
alors que la fillette n'a qu'un an,
ils partent s'installer au Liban,
car le régiment du jeune commandant
est dissous
et il accepte d'aller servir à Beyrouth.
Ce voyage est une expérience
forte pour De Gaulle.
Il y acquiert alors la conviction
que leur culture et leur histoire,
très éloignée de la nôtre,
pousseront inexorablement ces peuples
à vouloir s'émanciper.
Il estime qu'il faudra
un jour employer la force
ou partir.
En 1932,
il rentre à Paris et
il publie Le Fil de l'épée.
L'auteur prédit
un futur conflit européen
et affirme l'importance
du sentiment national,
de l'ardeur de l'armée
et du prestige du chef.
Il écrit.
Face à l'événement,
c'est à soi-même que
recourt l'homme de caractère.
Son mouvement est
d'imposer à l'action sa marque,
de la prendre à son compte,
d'en faire son affaire.
Deux ans après, en 1934,
De Gaulle publie un second livre,
Vers l'armée de métier.
Il martèle sa conception du chef.
Il faut qu'un maître apparaisse,
serviteur du seul État,
dépouillé de préjugés,
dédaigneux de clientèles,
pénétré de larges desseins
assez grands pour une grande œuvre.
Déjà apparaît le peu de cas
qu'il fait des partis politiques.
Il traite aussi
des nouvelles armes mécaniques.
L'Allemagne s'est lancée
dans la fabrication massive
d'une force blindée.
De Gaulle l'a vu avec effroi,
car il a compris
le rôle offensif des chars.
Il engage une croisade
pour que l'armée française
se dote des mêmes armes.
Pour tenter de se faire entendre,
il oublie son amour propre.
Hante les antichambres des ministères
et les rédactions des journaux.
Ses interlocuteurs ricanent
et le surnomme le colonel Motors.
Philippe Pétain
dénonce des fantasmagories.
Seul Paul Reynaud,
député de Paris, leader du centre droit,
se rallie aux thèses de De Gaulle.
Comment se faire entendre
par des marionnettes
politiques sûres d'elles-mêmes ?
J'avais des idées sur la façon de rénover
notre défense nationale.
Si on m'avait écouté,
on aurait évité le désastre
et probablement tué
l'entreprise d'Hitler dans l'œuf.
La guerre éclate le 3 septembre 1939,
quand les Allemands
envahissent la Pologne.
Commence alors la drôle de guerre.
Pendant huit mois,
les troupes françaises et anglaises
restent dans l'attente de l'affrontement.
En janvier 1940,
De Gaulle tente le tout pour le tout.
Sans respect pour les usages,
il adresse
à 80 personnalités un mémorandum
annonçant
le caractère mondial du conflit
et il plaide pour l'utilisation
des forces mécaniques,
les véhicules blindés et l'aviation.
Le 10 mai 1940,
l'Allemagne
prend l'initiative de l'assaut.
C'est la Blitzkrieg,
la guerre éclair,
une guerre où la vitesse de mouvement
bouscule les conceptions archaïques
de l'état major français.
Les armées nazies,
fortes de leur aviation,
de la puissance
et de la rapidité des véhicules blindés,
déferlent sur la France.
Le colonel De Gaulle,
à la tête
de la quatrième division cuirassée,
remporte de beaux succès.
À Abbeville et à Montcornet,
il stoppe un temps l'avance allemande.
Ses faits d'armes symboliques confirment
l'efficacité des forces blindées
et la validité des thèses de De Gaulle.
Il écrit est à son épouse le 24 mai 1940.
Ma chère petite femme chérie,
toujours la bagarre,
mais les choses
de mon côté ne vont pas mal.
Je suis général depuis hier.
Cependant, les armées
hitlériennes ne cessent de progresser.
Le 5 juin 1940,
De Gaulle est nommé
sous-secrétaire d'État à la Guerre.
Ce poste modeste va donner aux
militaires une légitimité politique
qui sera utile dans ses
relations avec les Anglais.
Dans le gouvernement,
Pétain plaide déjà
en faveur d'un armistice.
Le 9 juin 1940,
De Gaulle se rend à Londres
pour sa première
rencontre avec Winston Churchill,
nouveau Premier Ministre,
partisan de la lutte à outrance.
À son retour, alors qu'un immense
exode se déroule en direction du Sud,
et que des millions de Français
fuient sur les routes encombrées,
De Gaulle apprend que
le gouvernement va quitter Paris.
Le 14 juin,
la capitale est
investie par les troupes nazies.
Hitler s'y rendra
quelques jours plus tard.
Les ministres sont repliés à Bordeaux.
De Gaulle envisage déjà de continuer
le combat à partir de l'Afrique du Nord.
Il dit à
ses interlocuteurs anglais que pour lui,
Pétain et le commandant
en chef des armées,
le général Weygand, sont des traîtres.
Le 16 juin au soir,
Paul Reynaud démissionne.
Le vieux maréchal
Pétain est désormais au pouvoir.
Tôt le 17 juin,
De Gaulle quitte Bordeaux
à bord d'un avion britannique.
Churchill dira que ce petit avion
emporte l'honneur de la France.
Pour la France et Charles de Gaulle,
ce voyage est un tournant historique.
La grandeur est un chemin
vers quelque chose qu'on ne connaît pas.
Nous survolions
la forêt de la Bretagne en flammes.
Je risquais de ne plus jamais
revoir ma mère très malade,
et j'étais inquiet
pour Yvonne et les enfants
menacés par l'invasion allemande.
Le maréchal Pétain
fera condamner à mort le général rebelle.
À Londres,
De Gaulle va travailler
en étroite relation avec Churchill.
Les rapports entre les deux hommes seront
toujours difficiles, orageux, passionnés.
Le culte qu'ils portent à leur
pays ne facilite pas les compromis.
De Gaulle a dit
à ses premiers compagnons
que ses objectifs étaient
de défendre les intérêts de la France,
au besoin, contre ses alliés.
Hors norme,
nourris d'histoires,
le Français et l'Anglais ne donnent
leur mesure que dans l'adversité.
Circonstance aggravante,
la relation est déséquilibrée.
Churchill se trouve
en position de force
alors que De Gaulle est
entièrement dépendant.
Mais leur commune et farouche volonté
d'abattre Hitler soude leur entente.
Churchill offre
des bureaux au Français à Londres.
Dès le 19 juin,
Yvonne de Gaulle réussira
à rejoindre son mari avec ses enfants.
Les Anglais
ne connaissent pas De Gaulle.
Aussi, Churchill
imagine un reportage sur le couple
et le général doit se
plier à une séance photographique.
Un exercice qu'il déteste.
"Il veut me vendre comme une savonnette".
Le 17 juin 1940,
Pétain s'adresse aux Français.
"À l'appel de Monsieur
le président de la République",
"j'assume à partir d'aujourd'hui la
direction du Gouvernement de la France".
"Je fais à la France
le don de ma personne"
"pour atténuer son malheur".
"C'est le cœur serré, que je vous dis
aujourd'hui qu'il faut cesser le combat".
De Gaulle s'insurge et sans délai,
il prépare l'appel à la Résistance.
Le lendemain, 18 juin,
il s'exprime dans un studio
de la BBC avec le feu vert de Churchill.
Il déclare :
"L'espérance doit elle disparaître ?"
"La défaite est-elle définitive ? Non."
En France, peu de gens l'entendent
et l'appel n'est pas enregistré.
Le 22 juin,
Pétain signe l'armistice avec Hitler,
Le jour-même et les jours suivants,
le général réitère ses convictions
sur les ondes de la radio anglaise.
"Cette guerre n'est pas
une guerre franco-allemande"
"qu'une bataille puisse décider."
"Cette guerre est une guerre mondiale.
Il nous reste un vaste empire."
"Une flotte intacte. Beaucoup d'or."
"Il nous reste des alliés
dont les ressources sont immenses"
"et qui dominent les mers."
"Moi, général De Gaulle,"
"j'entreprends ici,
en Angleterre, cette tâche nationale."
Quelques jours après,
les Britanniques
anéantissent la flotte française
basée dans la rade
de Mers-el-Kébir, en Algérie,
par peur
que les Allemands s'en emparent.
1 380 militaires français
périssent dans cette attaque.
De Gaulle n'a pas été
consulté, ni même prévenu.
Il se trouve en porte à faux,
coincé entre la raison et le cœur.
"Il n'ait pas en français"
"qui n'ait appris avec douleur"
"et avec colère"
"que des navires de la flotte française
avaient été coulés par nos alliés."
"Leur destruction n'est
pas le résultat d'un combat glorieux."
Il enrage d'avoir été tenu
à l'écart de la décision,
mais reste loyal
envers les Britanniques.
Le général est convaincu
que les colonies françaises africaines
sont un point d'appui
essentiel dans le combat.
C'est un grand bout
de France non occupé.
Pour mettre la main sur Dakar,
la capitale
de l'Afrique occidentale française,
il décide d'organiser un raid
avec l'appui de la marine anglaise.
Devant Dakar,
la flotte est reçue
à coups de canon et l'opération échoue.
De Gaulle
est très affecté par cet échec.
Mais le soutien
de Churchill ne faiblit pas.
Il est vrai
que l'affaire était mal préparée.
La brume et la mauvaise
topographie des lieux
ont contrarié
l'effet de puissance de notre flotte.
La France de Vichy a tiré
sur les marins de la France libre.
J'ai ressenti les impressions d'un homme
dont un séisme
secoue brutalement la maison.
De Gaulle a vacillé.
Le fiasco de Dakar
va pourtant renforcer sa détermination.
Il prend la décision
de se diriger vers Brazzaville,
alors sous la tutelle de Vichy.
Sa pugnacité est récompensée.
Très vite, les ralliements se multiplient
et l'épopée de la France libre commence.
Churchill a reconnu De Gaulle
comme le chef des Français libres
qui parle au nom de son pays.
La France sera rassemblée toute entière
dans le dernier effort qui l'attend.
Un seul combat
pour une seule patrie.
Dès l'été 1940,
Churchill et De Gaulle se voient souvent.
Mais les accrochages se multiplient
et les tensions s'exacerbent.
Quand les Britanniques ménagent Vichy,
De Gaulle est intransigeant et irrite
Churchill, qui est tenté de l'écarter.
"Vous dites que vous êtes la France
mais vous ne l'êtes pas."
"Je ne vous reconnais
pas comme la France."
"Au lieu de faire la guerre à l'Allemagne,
vous l'avez faite à l'Angleterre."
Les entretiens entre les hommes
prennent parfois des formes si violentes
que les interprètes, ahuris, confieront
avoir été en présence de deux fous.
Cependant,
la rupture n'interviendra jamais.
À Vichy, Pétain entame
la collaboration avec l'Allemagne.
Les Français chantent :
"Maréchal nous voilà".
Ils sont nombreux
à soutenir Pétain, à l'acclamer.
Certains, bras tendus,
lui prêtent serment de fidélité.
Jusqu'au printemps 1941,
la Résistance ne résulte
que d'initiatives non coordonnées
venant de tous les horizons politiques.
Les réseaux se constituent peu à peu.
L'invasion de l'Union soviétique
par l'Allemagne nazie, en juin 1941,
change la situation.
Désormais, les communistes vont
fournir des bataillons à la Résistance.
De Gaulle considère que l'unification
de la Résistance est une priorité absolue.
Ce travail sera l'œuvre
du préfet Jean Moulin, radical de gauche.
Les deux hommes
s'entendent dès leur première rencontre.
De Gaulle a besoin
de rassembler les Français,
quelle que soit leur
sensibilité ou leur engagement politique.
Jean Moulin va représenter
De Gaulle dans la zone non occupée.
Il est parachuté en Provence
le 1er janvier 1942 et se met à l'œuvre.
Les résultats sont rapides.
Les divers mouvements
reconnaissent l'autorité du général.
Pierre Brossolette, également
envoyé en mission en France,
est méfiant à l'égard des communistes.
Il redoute le retour
des anciens partis politiques.
Mais Moulin
convainc De Gaulle qu'il en a besoin.
Le 27 mai 1943,
dans Paris occupé,
Jean Moulin,
représentant du chef de la France libre,
préside la première réunion
du Conseil national de la Résistance.
Les représentants
des partis y siègent également.
L'événement est historique.
Jean Moulin, dénoncé,
arrêté, torturé,
disparaît le 8 juillet 1943.
Pierre Brossolette sera aussi
arrêté et torturé par la Gestapo.
Le 22 mars 1944,
il se suicide pour ne pas parler.
Rentre ici, Jean Moulin,
avec ton terrible cortège.
Les deux hommes
reposent désormais au Panthéon.
La voix de Malraux
accompagne Moulin.
Aujourd'hui, jeunesse,
puisses-tu penser à cet homme
comme tu aurais approché tes mains
de sa pauvre face informe du dernier jour,
de ses lèvres qui n'avaient pas parlé
ce jour-là,
elle était le visage de la France.
Le 7 décembre 1941,
les Japonais attaquent par surprise
les États-Unis à Pearl Harbor.
Le jour d'après,
l'Amérique déclare la guerre au Japon.
De Gaulle l'avait prédit.
La guerre est devenue mondiale.
Un peu malgré eux,
les Américains
sont désormais engagés dans le conflit.
Au début,
ils vont conduire
une politique diplomatique ambiguë
à l'égard de Philippe Pétain.
Le président Roosevelt estime
que le régime de Vichy
est leur seul interlocuteur légal
et ils essaient de l'influencer.
En vain.
Vichy abolit la République,
édicte des lois antisémites,
collabore avec l'occupant.
Malgré cela, l'ambassadeur
américain reste auprès de Pétain.
Roosevelt tente d'écarter De Gaulle.
Il considère que c'est un homme
illégitime qui compte peu
et dont le caractère
intraitable complique ses projets.
Il craint aussi que la France
libérée ne tombe sous sa coupe.
Sa préférence va aux responsables
politiques d'avant guerre, plus dociles.
En Amérique,
De Gaulle est présenté
comme un homme de la droite la plus dure.
En même temps,
on le soupçonne
de complaisance envers les communistes.
De Gaulle a parié
sur les forces françaises
de l'empire colonial qui se rallient.
Elles affrontent
l'ennemi en Éthiopie,
au Soudan
et en Égypte.
En plein désert de Libye,
l'armée française se bat
contre des unités germano-italiennes.
Le général Kœnig affronte
le renard du désert Erwin Rommel.
Les Français combattent
pour permettre aux Britanniques
de se rétablir
sur de meilleures positions.
Malgré un ennemi
dix fois plus nombreux,
les Français
remportent la victoire à Bir-Hakeim.
Le général De Gaulle salue
l'action des forces françaises.
"Général Kœnig,
sachez et dites à vos troupes"
"que toute la France vous regarde
et que vous êtes son orgueil".
En dépit
de ses hauts faits d'armes,
De Gaulle
n'a pas été informé de l'opération Torch,
le débarquement allié
en Algérie et au Maroc,
le 8 novembre 1942.
Les Américains apportent aux grandes
affaires des sentiments élémentaires.
Ils ne connaissent que leurs intérêts.
Ils ignorent
presque tout du reste du monde,
sur lequel
ils n'ont que des idées simples.
Pour tenter de contrer De Gaulle,
Roosevelt reporte sa
confiance sur le général Giraud.
Giraud n'a pas de dimension
politique et il est jugé plus malléable.
Mais Roosevelt sous-estime
la combativité de De Gaulle,
renforcée par son autorité
sur la Résistance qui se réunifie.
En janvier 1943,
De Gaulle est invité près de Casablanca
pour y conférer
avec Churchill, Roosevelt et Giraud.
Il est furieux car le Maroc
est alors sous protectorat français
et le général
se considère chez lui.
En dépit
de la théâtrale poignée de main
dont Roosevelt demande la répétition,
Encore...
La conférence,
évidemment, se passe mal.
Rien n'est réglé.
Après sa rencontre avec De Gaulle,
Roosevelt est hargneux.
Il raconte que son interlocuteur s'est
comparé successivement à Jeanne d'Arc,
puis à Clémenceau.
Longtemps, les Américains
jouent la carte Giraud,
mais De Gaulle finit par s'imposer.
Face à Roosevelt,
le général dispose d'un appui inattendu,
l'opinion publique
américaine qui a évolué.
Au fil des mois, l'aventure
des Free French devient populaire.
L'écrivain William Faulkner
est même chargé d'écrire un scénario
pour populariser De Gaulle.
Roosevelt ne lâche pas prise.
Suprême humiliation,
Churchill n'informe De Gaulle de la date
du Débarquement que le 4 juin 1944,
48 heures avant l'opération.
Il lui annonce aussi
le projet américain d'installer
et de contrôler sur le territoire français
une nouvelle administration
et d'imposer une monnaie.
De Gaulle enrage, explose.
"Allez, faites la guerre
avec votre fausse monnaie."
Churchill lui propose de parler
à la radio après Eisenhower,
en même temps que la reine
des Pays-Bas et le souverain de Norvège.
"Et pourquoi pas le sultan
de Zanzibar pendant que vous y êtes ?"
tonne le général.
Finalement,
De Gaulle accepte de parler à la radio,
mais il refuse
de soumettre au préalable son texte.
À midi, Le 6 juin 1944,
il prend la parole
devant les micros de la BBC
et prononce
l'un de ses plus beaux discours.
"La bataille suprême est engagée."
"Après tant de combats,
de fureur, de douleur,"
"voici venu le choc décisif,"
"le choc tant espéré."
"Bien entendu,"
"c'est la bataille de France"
"et c'est la bataille de la France."
"Derrière le nuage si lourd
de notre sang et de nos larmes,"
"voici que reparaît
le soleil de notre grandeur."
Il se pose ainsi comme le seul
chef du gouvernement français.
De Gaulle a désormais conscience
de la nécessité d'agir sans tarder.
Il doit imposer son
leadership et son autorité au plus vite.
Le 14 juin 1944,
il débarque sur une plage
près de Courseulles.
Un collaborateur du général lui fait
remarquer que quatre ans auparavant,
les Allemands entraient dans Paris.
De Gaulle laisse tomber,
"Eh bien, ils ont eu tort."
Churchill a dit au général
Montgomery qui accueille De Gaulle,
"Je dois vous infliger
une visite du général de Gaulle."
"Ce sera un fardeau."
"Il n'est certainement
pas souhaitable pour lui"
"de rassembler
de larges foules à Bayeux".
Or, la visite de De Gaulle
à Bayeux est un triomphe.
De Gaulle pratique
la politique du fait accompli.
Il nomme partout des responsables
qui ne relèvent que de lui.
Churchill réitère
ses griefs contre De Gaulle.
Il craint que le général,
qui a été maltraité,
n'ait conçu
une profonde antipathie pour l'Angleterre.
Churchill était très inquiet.
Il savait que j'avais des raisons
de ne pas être bienveillant.
Mais finalement, pour le calmer,
je lui ai écrit pour verser du baume
sur les blessures
qu'il s'était faites à lui-même.
Les hommes peuvent avoir des amis.
Pas les chefs d'État.
De Gaulle
veut libérer Paris au plus tôt.
L'événement marquerait
symboliquement la victoire
et il redoute un coup
de force communiste dans la capitale.
À Paris,
la Résistance réclame
une intervention rapide des Alliés.
Eisenhower, sous les ordres
de Roosevelt, toujours très réservé,
accepte
alors de changer de stratégie.
Dès lors, tout se précipite.
Le 23 août,
De Gaulle est à Chartres, libéré.
Le 24,
la deuxième DB entre dans la capitale.
Le 25,
le général Von Choltitz,
commandant militaire allemand,
signe sa reddition devant Leclerc.
Le soir-même,
De Gaulle s'installe
au ministère de la Guerre,
qu'il a quitté quatre ans plus tôt.
Il constate :
"Rien n'y manque, excepté l'État".
"Il m'appartient de l'y remettre."
Un peu plus tôt, à l'Hôtel de ville,
il a prononcé un discours historique.
"Paris.
Paris outragé."
"Paris brisé,"
"Paris martyrisé,"
"mais Paris libéré !"
"Libéré par lui-même,"
"libéré par son peuple"
"avec le concours
des armées de la France,"
"avec l'appui et le concours
de la France tout entière !"
"C'est-à-dire de la France qui se bat,"
"c'est-à-dire de la seule France !"
"De la vraie France,
de la France éternelle !"
C'est la magie du verbe.
Il fait l'impasse
sur l'intervention des Alliés.
Il efface de la même façon Vichy,
qui, à ses yeux,
n'a jamais eu la moindre légitimité.
Le 26 août est le jour du sacre.
À pieds, il descend les Champs-Élysées
au milieu d'une foule en délire.
Il gagne ensuite Notre-Dame.
Alors qu'il est sur
le parvis de la cathédrale,
des coups de feu éclatent.
La foule se couche.
De Gaulle reste debout.
La guerre
n'est pas encore finie,
mais il sait qu'il a gagné
son formidable pari du 18 juin 1940.
Dans les jours qui suivent
la libération, la situation est confuse.
Certains groupes issus de la Résistance
renâclent à laisser le pouvoir.
Mais De Gaulle est inflexible,
il veut maîtriser la situation
et notamment, endiguer la montée
en puissance des communistes présents
dans le gouvernement
provisoire qu'il vient de former.
Désormais, sa priorité est
le rétablissement de l'autorité de l'État.
Dès le 15 septembre,
il entreprend
à cette fin une tournée dans les provinces
où il reçoit
un accueil triomphal.
Cependant, partout
où il passe, il se montre implacable.
"Vous avez bien compris,
il faut restaurer l'État."
lance-t-il à Marseille,
au commissaire
de la République Raymond Aubrac.
Ils n'ont pas bronché.
C'étaient des roseaux peints en fer.
Je leur ai dit qu'on ne fait pas
de révolution sans révolutionnaires
et qu'il n'y avait aucun révolutionnaire.
C'était moi.
La défaite de 1940
a frappé les esprits.
Pour être du côté des vainqueurs,
il faut que les soldats français
continuent à participer au combat.
De Gaulle s'y emploie.
L'Armée française
pèse dans le rapport des forces.
Au cours de l'année 1945,
325 000 hommes
et des renforts massifs
des forces françaises intérieures
sont présents dans les zones de combat.
Simultanément, pour montrer que la France
joue de nouveau dans la cour des grands,
fin 1944, il se rend à Moscou.
L'accueil est sans chaleur.
Staline apprécie l'indépendance
du général à l'égard des anglo-saxons.
Il se méfie en revanche
de ses orientations droitières.
Il attend surtout de lui
qu'il installe le Parti communiste
dans la vie politique française.
Les négociations sont difficiles.
Le tsar rouge n'appuie pas la France
dans ses revendications
vis-à-vis de l'Allemagne.
Il veut aussi que De Gaulle
soutienne le gouvernement polonais
qui est sous influence soviétique.
Les pourparlers
se poursuivent souvent la nuit.
Parfois, Staline se fait provocateur.
Les diplomates l'exaspèrent.
Le dictateur s'exclame,
"Allez me chercher une mitrailleuse
et mettez-les en joue !"
Staline était possédé
par la volonté de puissance.
Rompu à une vie de complots,
à se passer de pitié, de sincérité,
à voir en chaque homme
un obstacle ou un danger.
Tout était chez lui,
manœuvre, méfiance
et obstination.
Enfin,
dans la nuit du 9 au 10 décembre,
un accord est conclu,
un pacte est signé.
De Gaulle n'en est
pas entièrement satisfait.
Il a été contraint
de lâcher du lest sur la Pologne.
Mais il a aussi montré
que la France comptait.
De Gaulle est obsédé
par la nécessité d'asseoir la France
à la table des vainqueurs.
Sa ténacité a abouti
à un résultat inespéré.
Le 8 mai,
la France est
représentée par le général de Lattre
lors de la signature
de la capitulation allemande à Berlin.
Le maréchal Wilhelm Keitel
dirige la délégation allemande.
En entrant dans la salle,
il salue de son bâton
de maréchal les délégations alliées,
salutation à laquelle
personne ne répond.
Apercevant le drapeau
tricolore, il fait remarquer à haute voix
"Ah, il y a aussi des Français.
Il ne manquait plus que cela".
Je ne suis pas coupable !
Keitel finira pendu,
condamné à mort
par le tribunal de Nuremberg.
Trois mois après la signature
de la capitulation de l'Allemagne,
le 15 août 1945,
le maréchal Pétain, qui n'est plus
qu'un vieillard à moitié lucide,
est jugé et condamné à la peine de mort.
Mais eu égard à son grand âge,
De Gaulle commue la sentence
en peine de réclusion à perpétuité.
Lors d'une commémoration
de la bataille de Verdun,
il prononce ce discours
inattendu à propos de Philippe Pétain.
"Si par malheur en d'autres temps,"
"en l'extrême hiver de sa vie,"
"au milieu d'événements excessifs,"
"l'usure de l'âge
mena le maréchal Pétain"
"à des défaillances condamnables,"
"la gloire qu'il avait acquise à Verdun,"
"25 ans auparavant et qu'il garda,"
"ne saurait être contestée
ni méconnue par la patrie."
En 1944,
il avait aussi la volonté
de restaurer l'unité nationale
et de contenir les vagues
d'épuration, voire de vengeance.
Dans un discours à la radio,
il estime que "seule une poignée
de misérables et d'indignes"
"dont l'État fait et fera justice
ont collaboré avec les Allemands."
Il fallait réunifier
pour reconstruire le pays
car la France est dévastée.
À la tête de son gouvernement provisoire,
De Gaulle s'attaque à cette immense tâche.
Jusqu'en 1946,
il légifère à marche
forcée à un rythme exceptionnel,
avec de multiples ordonnances
pour redéfinir de fond en comble
le fonctionnement du pays.
Sur le plan social,
il refonde le statut
du monde agricole,
généralise le système
des assurances sociales
et met en place un dispositif
complet d'allocations familiales.
Il écrira que "si malheureusement,
il y aura toujours des pauvres en France,"
"il y aura moins de misérables."
Il accorde le droit de vote
et d'éligibilité aux femmes.
De Gaulle va mener
un combat contre le communisme
sans reconnaître pour autant
des valeurs humaines au capitalisme.
Pour lui, c'est l'État avant tout,
qui doit apporter l'équilibre.
Dans le domaine
économique et industriel,
il nationalise Air France,
les Houillères,
les usines Renault,
neuf compagnies d'assurances,
la Banque de France
et quatre banques de dépôt.
Il place sous le contrôle
de l'État le gaz et l'électricité.
Le nucléaire va être au centre
de sa politique d'indépendance nationale.
Il fonde
le Commissariat à l'énergie atomique
pour le développement
des centrales d'électricité
et la mise
au point de l'arme nucléaire.
De Gaulle le savait.
Après la guerre, les vieux partis
risquaient de lui rendre la vie dure.
Il en a vite la confirmation.
Il a désormais la conviction
qu'il joue un rôle néfaste.
Qu'il défende des intérêts partisans
au détriment des intérêts du pays.
Il ne décolère pas.
Ça ne cessera jamais.
La frénésie des partis
est sans limite, accablante.
La guerre n'a rien changé
à leurs réflexes politiques
et c'est avec ça,
à la fin de la guerre,
qu'il fallait reconstruire
la République, l'État, la France.
Le général commence
par tenter de composer, en vain.
Hors de lui, il décide
de démissionner le 20 janvier 1946.
Stupeur dans l'opinion.
En réalité,
De Gaulle a voulu créer un choc.
Il espère que les Français
vont le rappeler pour continuer sa tâche.
Il a besoin de ce lien pour compenser
les manœuvres des partis.
Il oublie que même
Churchill a été battu aux élections
et que la gratitude
n'est pas une valeur populaire.
Le peuple semble
vouloir oublier la guerre
et De Gaulle s'engage sans le savoir
dans une longue traversée du désert.
L'actualité va le désespérer.
La quatrième
République est crépusculaire,
mais elle se révèle
plus solide qu'il aurait pu le croire.
Le général enrage et il va
sortir rapidement de sa réserve.
Premier signe fort,
à peine six mois après son départ.
Dans un discours prononcé à Bayeux,
ville symbole de la Libération,
il annonce sa vision
des futures institutions de la France.
"C'est du chef de l'État
que doit procéder le pouvoir exécutif."
"À lui la charge d'accorder"
"les nécessités générales
concernant le choix des hommes"
"avec l'orientation
qui se dégage du Parlement."
"À lui la mission
de nommer les ministres"
"et d'abord naturellement, le Premier,"
"qui a la charge,
lui, de diriger l'action,"
"la politique
et le travail du gouvernement."
Il appelle à une nouvelle Constitution
avec primauté absolue de l'exécutif.
C'est l'amorce d'un projet
de régime à caractère présidentiel,
avec à la tête
de l'État, un homme fort.
Il définit un vaste territoire
des prérogatives du président.
Il oppose un chef
qui rassemble à des partis qui divisent.
Son discours déclenche un flot
de critiques, en particulier à gauche.
Le libérateur
est accusé d'être un factieux.
Dans l'esprit
de Bayeux, un an après,
il crée le 14 avril 1947,
le Rassemblement du peuple français.
Le RPF,
un mouvement
et non un parti comme les autres.
Il veut rassembler
au-delà des frontières partisanes.
Il parcourt la France,
Strasbourg, Lille,
Rennes, Bordeaux.
"Convaincu de toute mon
âme et de toute ma raison"
"que le redressement est possible
sur les bases que je vais tracer,"
"je prétends
que le régime ne peut y réussir"
"et qu'il nous faut en faire un autre."
Et d'autres villes encore
où des centaines de milliers de Français
lui réservent un accueil digne d'un chef
d'État et acclament ses discours.
"Où est l'avenir ?"
"Il est en nous."
Au début,
le succès du RPF semble assuré.
Près de 40% des électeurs
le soutiennent aux
élections municipales de l'automne 1947.
Mais assez vite,
le mouvement s'essouffle.
De Gaulle a rencontré l'histoire.
Face à Roosevelt, Churchill
ou Staline, il savait comment réagir.
Confronté aux chefs de parti,
il se révèle inadapté, maladroit.
Ses adversaires
ne combattent pas sur le même terrain.
Six ans après, en 1953,
las et usé par des affrontements
politiciens qu'il méprise,
il met le RPF en sommeil.
Il tirera plus tard,
avec son humour dépouillé,
les leçons de ses combats politiques.
"Comment gouverner un pays
qui compte 265 spécialités de fromages ?"
Il s'enferme
dans le silence de La Boisserie
pour raconter
avec un ton aussi lyrique qu'incisif,
les prodigieuses
aventures de la France libre,
opposée à la médiocrité
du monde politique.
Il trempe parfois
sa plume dans le vitriol.
Ainsi, à propos d'Albert Lebrun,
président de la République
avant juin 1940, il écrit,
"Au fond comme chef de l'État,
deux choses lui auront manqué,"
"qu'il fût un chef
et qu'il y eut un État".
De Gaulle avait deux armes,
l'épée et la plume.
Publié en 1954,
le premier tome des
Mémoires de guerre est un immense succès.
La même année,
de l'autre côté de la Méditerranée,
en Algérie, qui est un territoire
découpé en départements français,
gronde une révolte
surgie à la Toussaint.
Quatre ans plus tard,
à partir de février 1958,
la situation se dégrade.
L'Armée et les Français d'Algérie
reprochent aux gouvernements successifs
de ne pas avoir su régler la crise
et la révolte algérienne qui
se sont transformées en guerre.
Pour les partisans de l'Algérie française,
De Gaulle est l'homme de la situation.
Nous étions en présence d'une vague
qui emportait tous
les peuples vers l'émancipation.
Il y avait des idiots
qui ne voulaient pas le voir.
Je n'étais pas sûr de pouvoir
nous maintenir en Afrique du Nord.
Le général sait qu'on avance
son nom pour résoudre la crise.
Il multiplie
discrètement les contacts.
Il parle
peu et écoute beaucoup.
Mais il pose ses conditions,
notamment la nécessité de pouvoir décider.
Il précise : "Dictature,
non, mais pleins pouvoirs, certes".
Il reste évasif sur ses
intentions concernant l'Algérie.
Mais laisse entendre aux militaires
et aux partisans de l'Algérie française
qu'il ne lâchera rien.
Le 13 mai 1958 à Alger,
la crise prend
des allures de guerre civile.
Un Comité de salut public
présidé par les généraux
Salan et Massu est mis en place.
Deux jours plus tard, le 15 mai,
du haut d'un balcon
face au Forum d'Alger,
le général Salan
fait acclamer De Gaulle.
"Mes amis, vive la France !"
"Vive l'Algérie Française !"
"Vive le général de Gaulle !"
La foule reprend
et chante La Marseillaise.
Le gouvernement est impuissant.
Tous les regards
se tournent alors vers Colombey.
Par un communiqué,
le général
fait savoir qu'il se tient prêt.
Naguère,
le pays dans ses profondeurs
m'a fait confiance pour le conduire
tout entier jusqu'à son salut.
Aujourd'hui, devant les épreuves
qui montent de nouveau vers lui,
qu'il sache que je me tiens prêt
à assumer les pouvoirs de la République.
Quatre jours plus tard,
le 19 mai,
500 journalistes l'attendent
pour une conférence
de presse qui fera date.
"La seule chose à faire,"
"c'est ce qui doit empêcher"
"que l'Algérie s'écarte de la France,
il faut qu'elle reste avec nous."
"Et quant à l'armée qui est,
normalement, l'instrument de l'État,"
"eh bien,
encore faut-il qu'il y en ait un, État."
"Est-ce que vous garantiriez
les libertés publiques fondamentales ?"
"Est-ce que je n'ai jamais attenté
aux libertés publiques fondamentales ?"
"Je les ai rétablies."
"Y ai-je a une seconde attenté ?
Jamais."
"Pourquoi voulez-vous qu'à 67 ans,
je commence une carrière de dictateur ?"
Par ces déclarations,
De Gaulle déstabilise le gouvernement
et à Alger,
la tension monte encore.
Certains annoncent que,
dans le cadre de l'opération Résurrection,
des parachutistes
s'apprêtent à sauter sur Paris.
La crise est dénouée par le président
de la République, René Coty.
Le 29 mai,
il fait appel à De Gaulle
et adresse un message
aux députés et aux sénateurs.
"Le pays étant
au bord de la guerre civile,"
"je me suis tourné vers
le plus illustre des Français,"
"vers celui qui, aux heures
les plus sombres de notre histoire,"
"fut notre chef."
Trois jours plus tard,
le 1er juin,
De Gaulle se présente devant l'Assemblée.
Une séance historique.
Il évoque, non sans ironie,
le plaisir et l'honneur qu'il ressent
à se retrouver dans cette enceinte.
Il obtient les pleins
pouvoirs pour six mois.
Il veut rédiger
une nouvelle Constitution.
Il s'installe à Matignon.
À ses côtés,
un puissant
ministre de la Justice,
Michel Debré,
et un directeur de cabinet
qui s'appelle Georges Pompidou.
En priorité,
De Gaulle doit
se saisir du dossier algérien,
car ce qui est encore
pudiquement appelé "Les événements"
est une guerre particulièrement
cruelle pour les populations civiles.
Dès le 4 juin 1958,
il se rend à Alger.
Une foule considérable l'y attend.
"Je vous ai compris."
La formule gaullienne est suffisamment
ambiguë pour satisfaire tout le monde.
Mais deux jours
plus tard, à Mostaganem,
le discours est plus direct.
"Vive l'Algérie Française !"
"Vive la France !"
Je savais que
l'Algérie de papa était morte.
Mais comment en sortir ?
Si je m'étais engagé trop tôt,
j'aurais soulevé toutes les oppositions.
Après avoir tenté
de rassurer le peuple d'Algérie,
il doit également engager
toute une série de réformes.
Et pendant l'été 1958, comme en 1945,
De Gaulle légifère par ordonnances.
"J'ai décidé
de remettre les affaires en ordre"
"réellement et profondément."
Comme après la guerre,
De Gaulle réforme
le pays au pas de charge,
notamment
dans le domaine économique.
Ses objectifs sont de réduire
l'inflation et le déficit budgétaire
et augmenter les réserves de devises.
On alourdit les taxes
sur le tabac et l'alcool,
les tarifs
du gaz et de l'électricité.
On créera le nouveau franc.
L'économie française
s'ouvre sur le monde.
De Gaulle prépare
un projet de Constitution
qui consacre le pouvoir de l'exécutif,
notamment celui du Président.
C'est son objectif de toujours
et c'est une révolution pour la France.
"C'est dans la légalité que, moi-même,
et mon gouvernement avons assumé."
"Avons assumé
le mandat exceptionnel"
"d'établir un projet
de Constitution nouvelle"
"et de le soumettre
à la décision du peuple."
Le peuple,
consulté le 28 septembre 1958,
approuve massivement, par plus
de 80 % de oui, la nouvelle Constitution.
Elle donne naissance
à la cinquième République.
Le 21 décembre,
De Gaulle triomphe.
Il est élu par un collège
de 80 000 votants
et devient le premier
président de la Cinquième République.
Il s'installe au palais de l'Élysée
le 8 janvier 1959.
"Monsieur
le président de la République,"
"le premier des Français"
"et désormais
le premier en France."
Première tâche,
former un nouveau gouvernement.
De Gaulle
désigne Michel Debré,
fidèle à l'Algérie française,
au poste de Premier ministre.
Désormais, les principaux
arbitrages remontent à l'Élysée.
C'est là que la politique de défense
et la politique étrangère seront définies.
C'est le domaine réservé.
Cela vaut d'abord pour l'Algérie.
Sur cette crise douloureuse,
De Gaulle n'a pas encore
manifesté d'opinion définitive.
Acquis à l'idée d'évolution réelle,
il voulait pouvoir
aménager une longue transition.
Le 16 septembre 1959,
il lève toute ambiguïté.
"Le sort des Algériens
appartient aux Algériens,"
"non pas comme le leur imposerait
les couteaux et les mitraillettes,"
"mais, comme ils le diront eux-mêmes,"
"légitimement,
par le suffrage universel."
Choqués,
les partisans de l'Algérie Française
qui l'ont soutenu l'abandonnent.
C'est le début d'une longue
épreuve de force ponctuée de drames.
Fin janvier 1960,
éclate à Alger la semaine des barricades.
La rébellion est matée.
Mais le malaise
s'accroît dans l'armée.
Le 8 janvier 1961,
par référendum,
les électeurs valident à 75 %
l'autodétermination algérienne.
Les Français
sont las de cette guerre.
Ils ne veulent plus que leurs enfants
aillent mourir de l'autre côté de la mer.
Du côté des partisans
de l'Algérie Française,
la colère monte.
Ils voient en De Gaulle un traître.
Une partie de l'armée
se rallie à leur position.
Le 21 avril 1961 à Alger,
quatre généraux,
Challe, Salan, Jouhaud, Zeller
tentent un coup d'État militaire.
La France est inquiète.
L'Armée se déploie
pour protéger les sites sensibles.
Deux jours plus tard,
De Gaulle intervient.
C'est le chef
qui s'exprime en grand uniforme.
"Un pouvoir
insurrectionnel s'est établi en Algérie"
"par un pronunciamiento militaire."
"Ce pouvoir a une apparence."
"Un quarteron
de généraux en retraite."
"Il a une réalité."
"Un groupe d'officiers partisans,"
"ambitieux et fanatiques."
"Au nom de la France,
j'ordonne que tous les moyens,"
"je dis tous les moyens,"
"soient employés partout"
"pour barrer
la route à ces hommes-là"
"en attendant de les réduire."
L'insurrection échoue.
Mais un mouvement subversif, l'OAS,
l'Organisation de l'armée secrète
sème la terreur
et multiplie les attentats meurtriers
au nom
de l'Algérie Française.
Jusqu'au bout,
De Gaulle veut trouver
un autre interlocuteur que
le Front de libération nationale algérien
et conserver le Sahara.
En vain.
La pression internationale est trop forte.
Rien n'arrête
le processus de paix.
Le 18 mars 1962,
les accords d'Évian
consacrent l'indépendance de l'Algérie.
Le 8 avril,
les Français sont consultés
à nouveau par référendum
et approuvent
à 91 % ces accords.
De ses sentiments profonds,
De Gaulle ne dira rien.
Dans une des premières
versions de ses Mémoires d'espoir
à propos du drame algérien,
il aurait écrit,
"Et que Dieu me prenne en pitié."
C'est une page
qui commence à se tourner.
Michel Debré,
attaché à l'Algérie française,
est remplacé à Matignon
par Georges Pompidou.
Un quasi inconnu
qui doit tout au général.
Pompidou,
ancien directeur de la banque Rothschild,
n'a jamais été parlementaire,
ce qui provoque des critiques.
Le général
n'y prête guère attention.
Pour lui, l'essentiel maintenant,
est de résoudre les problèmes économiques.
De Gaulle veut aussi peser
davantage sur la scène mondiale.
Il refuse
la politique des blocs est-ouest.
Il a reçu en France,
le 23 mars 1960 Nikita Khrouchtchev,
premier secrétaire du Parti
communiste de l'Union soviétique.
En juin 1961,
il reçoit le couple Kennedy.
Une visite qui fait l'événement.
"Mesdames et messieurs,"
"je ne pense pas qu'il soit
superflu que je me présente à vous."
"Je suis le type qui accompagne
Jackie Kennedy à Paris, et j’adore ça."
Les gazettes de l'époque
ont enjolivé la relation
entre la première dame et le général,
dont on a dit qu'il était sous le charme.
Mais quand Jackie Kennedy susurre
au président
qu'elle a des origines françaises,
De Gaulle lui répond,
moqueur "Moi aussi, Madame !"
Le président poursuit
le redressement économique de la France.
Il fixe les grandes orientations
que Georges Pompidou
est chargé de mettre en œuvre.
Cependant, un différend va
surgir lié à la guerre d'Algérie.
Jouhaud, l'un des quatre
généraux rebelles du putsch d'avril 1961,
est condamné à mort.
Le général est favorable à l'exécution.
Pompidou s'y oppose
et menace même de démissionner.
Jouhaud sera finalement gracié.
Les séquelles de la crise algérienne
sont humainement très douloureuses.
Le rapatriement
d'un million de Pieds-noirs
se déroule dans des conditions
particulièrement difficiles.
Après les premiers départs
des militaires français,
les harkis, ces combattants
algériens fidèles à la France,
se font massacrer
en très grand nombre.
On parle
généralement de 60 à 80 000 morts.
De Gaulle et son gouvernement
se verront vivement reprocher
de ne pas avoir su
empêcher ce drame sanglant.
Et la plupart de ceux
qui arrivent en France
vont être
durement et longuement parqués
dans des camps
de transit et de reclassement.
Depuis que le processus
d'indépendance est engagé,
l'OAS s'est lancée
dans des actions désespérées.
Le 22 août 1962,
au Petit Clamart, près de Paris,
De Gaulle est victime d'un attentat.
Un commando
a préparé avec soin l'opération.
La DS du président
est criblée de balles.
On retrouve
plus de 150 douilles sur le sol.
Quatorze impacts de balles
sont relevés sur la carrosserie.
Le couple
présidentiel en réchappe par miracle.
Quand Yvonne de Gaulle se
préoccupe du sort des poulets,
le chef du service
de sécurité la rassure.
Ses hommes n'ont rien.
Mais en ouvrant le coffre de la DS,
l'officier de police découvre
la présence de vrais poulets
en partance pour Colombey.
Quels crétins,
incapables de m'atteindre.
Et ils m'ont donné des arguments
pour faire élire le président
de la République au suffrage universel.
En effet, dans tout le pays,
après cet attentat,
l'émotion est considérable.
De Gaulle décide de frapper le grand
coup qu'il mûrissait depuis longtemps.
"Ma disparition
risquerait de replonger la France"
"dans la confusion naguère"
"et bientôt dans la catastrophe."
"Je crois que quoi qu'il arrive,"
"la Nation doit avoir le moyen"
"de choisir elle-même son président"
"afin que cette investiture directe"
"puisse lui donner la force"
"et l'obligation d'être
le guide de la France"
"et le garant de l'État."
Ainsi, pour De Gaulle,
la République ne peut se passer
d'un pouvoir exécutif fort et légitime.
Et cette légitimité
ne peut venir que du peuple.
Le Parlement
se sent marginalisé
et une grande partie de la classe
politique se dresse contre ce projet.
Le président du Sénat,
Gaston Monnerville,
prend la tête du combat.
Même Paul Reynaud,
proche du général en 1940 s'insurge.
"Aussi,
Monsieur le Premier ministre,"
"allez dire à l'Elysée que notre
admiration pour le passé est intacte,"
"mais que cette assemblée n'est pas assez
dégénérée pour renier la République."
La fronde parlementaire
s'organise dans un climat houleux
qui aboutit à la censure.
Comme l'exige la Constitution,
Pompidou doit présenter sa démission.
Ce bras de fer renforce encore la vindicte
de De Gaulle contre les partis.
"Aujourd'hui,
mon action à la tête de la République."
"Plus tard, celle de présidents
successifs sont incompatibles"
"avec le règne
absolu et désastreux des partisans."
Deux mois durant,
De Gaulle est à la manœuvre.
Il joue en deux actes majeurs.
Pour répondre
au vote de la censure,
il dissout l'Assemblée,
provoquant ainsi
des élections législatives.
Et il convoque d'abord un référendum
sur une question claire.
"Voulez-vous, dorénavant,"
"élire vous-même"
"votre président
au suffrage universel ?"
Le oui l'emporte à 62 %.
Sur le coup
et malgré l'ampleur du résultat,
De Gaulle est d'abord déçu car on est loin
des scores des référendums précédents.
Mais la victoire est nette
et un mois plus tard,
ses partisans gagnent
les élections législatives.
Finalement,
De Gaulle estime qu'il a atteint son but.
Désormais élu
au suffrage universel,
le président
dispose d'un pouvoir renforcé.
Une nouvelle période
s'ouvre pour la République gaullienne.
Huit semaines après la censure,
Pompidou est renommé Premier ministre.
Il s'occupe
du quotidien des Français.
L'économie
se porte plutôt bien.
Cependant, durant l'hiver 1963,
une grève des mineurs,
très dure, est mal gérée par le pouvoir.
Le Premier ministre appelle
les grévistes à reprendre le travail.
"Dans les circonstances actuelles,"
"c'est l'intérêt et le devoir des mineurs"
"de ne pas se dérober à des obligations,"
"qui, à mes yeux,
sont moins légales que morales"
"et qui consistent à assurer"
"le ravitaillement
de la nation en combustible."
L'appel n'est pas entendu.
Pour la première fois,
sous la Cinquième République,
le Gouvernement doit reculer.
Pompidou, pas de charbon !
Pendant que Pompidou
gère les problèmes intérieurs,
De Gaulle veut être avant tout
l'homme des grands desseins.
Avec une feuille de route précise,
il veut rétablir les conditions
de la grandeur de la France,
renforcer son indépendance,
notamment à l'égard des États-Unis,
et bâtir une Europe des États,
une Europe solidaire et puissante
mais qui respecte la culture des nations.
"Je ne crois pas que l'Europe"
"puisse avoir ou aucune réalité vivante,"
"si elle ne comporte
pas la France avec ses Français,"
"l'Allemagne avec ses Allemands,"
"l'Italie avec ses Italiens, etc."
"Dante, Goethe,
Chateaubriand,"
"appartiennent
à toute l'Europe."
"Dans la mesure même"
"où ils étaient
respectivement et éminemment"
"italien,
allemand et français."
"Ils n'auraient pas beaucoup servi
l'Europe s'ils avaient été des apatrides"
"et qu'ils avaient pensé et écrit"
"en quelques esperanto
ou volapük intégrés."
Première étape, sceller
la réconciliation franco-allemande.
En septembre 1958,
pas encore président,
il avait invité
le chancelier allemand Konrad Adenauer
à son domicile
familial de La Boisserie.
Un moment historique.
En juillet 1962,
Adenauer vient
en visite officielle en France.
Deux mois plus tard,
De Gaulle est en Allemagne.
À chaque étape, il parle.
Et il parle en allemand.
"À vous tous, je demande
de vous joindre à moi"
"pour célébrer un fait nouveau,"
"l’un des plus grands
des temps modernes :"
"l’amitié de l’Allemagne"
"et de la France."
L'accueil est triomphal.
La réconciliation
franco-allemande est consacrée.
Mais de Gaulle a des arrière pensées.
À terme, il veut détacher
l'Allemagne fédérale des États-Unis.
Toujours avec
la même volonté d'affranchir l'Europe
de l'influence américaine,
il s'oppose à l'entrée
de la Grande-Bretagne
dans le marché commun.
Il met en doute
l'esprit européen du Royaume-Uni.
Pour lui, l'Angleterre ne serait
que le cheval de Troie de l'Amérique.
"Faire entrer l'Angleterre,
ce serait pour les six,"
"donner d'avance leur consentement à tous
les artifices, délais et faux semblants,"
"qui tendraient à dissimuler"
"la destruction
d'un édifice qui a été bâti"
"au prix de tant de peines
et au milieu de tant d'espoirs."
En mars 1964, il fait
un premier voyage au Mexique.
"Le peuple de Français
propose au peuple Mexicain"
"de marcher la main dans la main."
À l'automne de la même année,
il entame une tournée
dans toute l'Amérique latine.
Un long voyage de dix étapes.
Il exhorte ses hôtes à prendre
leur distance avec les États-Unis.
Les foules sont immenses et chaleureuses.
De Gaulle et la France fascinent.
Dans cette même année,
De Gaulle est aussi le premier à établir
les relations diplomatiques
avec la Chine de Mao.
Il a dit à l'ambassadeur des États-Unis,
"Les Chinois ne seront pas
toujours communistes."
"Il faut compter tout au plus
une cinquantaine d'années."
Fidel Castro
lui rend un hommage appuyé et inattendu.
En ce moment,
j'étudie longuement"
"les mémoires de De Gaulle."
"Il y a plusieurs choses dans
la politique internationale de De Gaulle"
"avec lesquelles
je sympathise sincèrement."
"Son attitude ferme et résolue
à défendre son indépendance"
"vis-à-vis des États-Unis,"
"Sa manifestation
du sentiment national français,"
"de pleine et absolue
souveraineté devant toute tutelle."
Le leader maximo cubain
manifeste aussi son admiration
en envoyant des cigares au général.
Charles de Gaulle a près de 75 ans
et il semble au sommet de sa gloire.
L'épreuve
de la guerre d'Algérie s'éloigne.
La France bénéficie de la croissance
exceptionnelle des 30 Glorieuses.
Rien, en apparence, ne semble
pouvoir compromettre cet équilibre.
Sauf peut-être
l'usure inexorable du pouvoir.
En automne 1965,
l'élection du président
au suffrage universel approche.
Le général va-t-il se représenter ?
Madame De Gaulle y est hostile.
Elle déteste l'Élysée, la vie
publique et ses contraintes.
Personne ne connaît
les intentions du général.
Pas même
Georges Pompidou qui vit mal la situation.
Je connaissais le poids de la tâche
et j'avais envie de me retrouver ici,
dans la paix de Colombey.
Mais il y avait encore beaucoup à faire,
l'État livré aux partis sombrerait
à nouveau dans l'impuissance.
Alors, j'y suis retourné.
Le 4 novembre, De Gaulle
annonce sa candidature.
"Aujourd'hui,"
"je crois devoir
me tenir prêt à poursuivre ma tâche,"
"mesurant en connaissance de cause"
"de quel effort il s'agit."
"Mais convaincu qu'actuellement,"
"c'est le mieux pour servir la France."
La campagne électorale
est plus difficile que prévu.
François Mitterrand,
le candidat de la Gauche unie,
l'attaque sur l'exercice
d'un pouvoir trop personnel.
"Je pense que le général
De Gaulle ne peut pas tout voir."
"Il est très difficile à un chef d'Etat
qui veut tous les pouvoirs,"
"d'arriver à les maintenir
dans ses mains."
"La démocratie, c'est une autre chose."
Sûr de sa légitimité historique,
de son lien avec les Français
qu'il vérifie à chaque déplacement
et de son bilan,
De Gaulle refuse de faire réellement
campagne à la télévision.
Il renonce à utiliser
une grande partie de son temps de parole.
Il entend être élu au premier tour.
C'est une erreur.
À l'approche du vote,
les écarts se resserrent.
Le 5 décembre,
c'est un énorme choc politique.
Avec moins de 45 % des voix,
De Gaulle est en ballottage.
Le général est ébranlé.
Son orgueil le pousse à se
retirer, mais l'idée de laisser le pouvoir
à François Mitterrand
l'incite à se maintenir.
Cette fois, il s'exprime
longuement à la télévision.
Lors de ses trois entretiens
avec le journaliste Michel Droit,
De Gaulle parle moins
de la France, et plus des Français.
Ces interviews
révèlent aux téléspectateurs,
un personnage à la fois
drôle, caustique et souverain.
"Les Français ont souvent l'impression
que vous êtes davantage préoccupé"
"de la conduite des affaires
de la France à un niveau très élevé,"
"que de leurs propres problèmes à eux,"
"que vous ne vous intéressiez pas
beaucoup à l'intendance."
"En effet, on m'a prêté
ce mot que je n'ai jamais dit,"
"et à plus forte raison,
je n'ai jamais pensé l'intendance suit."
"Ce sont des blagues pour les journaux."
"Je n'ai pas besoin
de vous dire ce que j'entends par là."
"Pour que la France soit forte,"
"il faut que
les Français soient prospères,"
"autant que possible, bien entendu."
Au fil du temps,
beaucoup se sont interrogés
sur le véritable positionnement politique
du général.
Le journaliste lui pose la question.
"J'aimerais que vous précisiez
la façon dont vous les entendez,"
"dont vous les concevez,
ces notions de gauche et de droite."
"La France, c'est tout à la fois,"
"c'est tous les Français."
"Ce n'est pas la gauche, la France."
"Ce n'est pas la droite, la France."
"Naturellement les Français,"
"comme de tout temps,"
"ils l'ont eu."
"Ils ressentent en eux du courant."
"Il y a l'éternel
courant du mouvement."
"Qui va aux réformes, qui va"
"au changement et qui
est naturellement nécessaire."
"Puis, il y a aussi
un courant de l'ordre, de la règle,"
"de la tradition,
qui est aussi nécessaire."
"C'est avec tout ça,
qu'on fait la France."
"Il y a pour ce qui est de la France,"
"et qui se passe dans une maison,"
"la maîtresse de maison, la ménagère,"
"elle veut avoir
un aspirateur, avoir un frigidaire."
"Elle veut avoir une machine à laver."
"Et même, si c'est possible,
conduire une auto."
"Ça, c'est du mouvement."
"En même temps, elle ne veut pas
que son mari s'en aille bambocher"
"quelque part,"
"que les garçons
mettent les pieds sur la table,"
"et que les filles
ne rentrent pas la nuit."
"Ça, c'est l'ordre."
"La ménagère veut le progrès,"
"mais elle ne veut pas la pagaille."
"C'est vrai aussi pour la France,"
"il faut le progrès,
il ne faut pas la pagaille."
Le 19 décembre,
de Gaulle l'emporte
avec 55 % des suffrages,
contre 45 % pour Mitterrand.
Après cette mise en ballottage,
rien ne sera plus comme avant,
entre De Gaulle et les Français.
Le général reconduit dans
ses fonctions Georges Pompidou.
En revanche,
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing
est écarté du ministère des Finances.
Sur la scène internationale,
De Gaulle prend des positions fortes.
Il prononce
des phrases qui secouent l'opinion.
Il continue à s'opposer
à l'hyperpuissance américaine.
En mai 1966,
il annonce le retrait de la France
du commandement intégré de l'OTAN,
qui disposait jusque-là d'une
quinzaine de bases militaires en France.
"Et enfin la volonté de la France,"
"de disposer d'elle-même,"
"ce qui est indispensable
pour qu'elle croie à son propre rôle,"
"et pour qu'elle puisse
être utile aux autres."
"Cette volonté
de la France est incompatible"
"avec une organisation de défense
dans laquelle elle est subordonnée."
Washington parle
d'un coup de poignard.
La tension monte.
Le 1ᵉʳ septembre,
De Gaulle prononce
au Cambodge, à Phnom Penh,
un discours dénonçant
violemment l'intervention américaine
au Vietnam.
"Il n'y a aucune chance,"
"pour que les peuples de l'Asie
se soumettent à la loi d'un étranger venu"
"de l'autre rive du Pacifique,"
"quelles que puisse être ses intentions,"
"et quelle que soit
la puissance de ses armes."
Au printemps 1967,
quand éclate la guerre des Six Jours,
il se démarque pareillement
en prenant ses distances avec Israël,
et en décrétant
un embargo sur les ventes d'armes.
Il précise sa position au cours
d'une surprenante conférence de presse
à l'automne.
"Certains même redoutaient
que les Juifs, jusqu'alors dispersés,"
"mais qui étaient restés ce
qu'ils avaient été de tout temps."
"C'est-à-dire,"
"un peuple d'élite,"
"sûr de lui-même,"
"et dominateur."
Le propos choque,
et suscite bien sûr une grande émotion
et de vives polémiques.
En juillet 1967,
il avait déjà surpris à l'occasion
d'une visite officielle au Québec.
Il y avait été accueilli avec ferveur,
et à Montréal, il avait prononcé
depuis le balcon de l'hôtel de ville,
un discours qui laissera
des traces dans les mémoires.
"Vive le Québec libre !"
De Gaulle avait bien perçu
la volonté des Québécois de s'émanciper
de la tutelle anglo-saxonne.
"Vive le Canada français"
"et vive la France !"
Mais la méthode heurte les esprits.
En France, l'opposition réagit vivement.
Depuis les élections de mars 1967,
la stabilité du gouvernement Pompidou est
entre les mains des alliés centristes
et giscardiens.
Scrutin après scrutin,
les soutiens au général s'érodent.
À la veille de 1968,
Pompidou gère
un pays qui se porte plutôt bien.
Lors de ses vœux
du 31 décembre 1967,
le Général cite Verlaine.
"Mon Dieu, mon Dieu ! La vie est là."
"Simple et tranquille."
Cependant, un éditorialiste
du journal Le Monde écrit,
"Quand la France s'ennuie."
La stabilité
de la cinquième République lasse,
les mœurs ont changé.
La France se déchristianise.
Les femmes
revendiquent leurs droits.
Aux États-Unis,
une vague de jeunes contestataires,
portée par la voix de Joan Baez,
appelle à un changement de valeurs.
À Paris,
à partir du mois de mars,
l'agitation monte dans les facultés.
Les étudiants ne veulent plus
de la séparation des garçons et des filles
dans les dortoirs
des cités universitaires.
Petite cause, grands effets.
La France explose dans
un mouvement confus, parfois violent,
chargé d'utopies.
Soyez réalistes, demandez l'impossible.
En quelques semaines,
le pays est paralysé par la grève.
La classe politique
et les syndicats sont dépassés.
De Gaulle est sidéré.
Lui, qui avait été confronté
à l'horreur des guerres,
à l'occupation nazie.
Pouvait-il admettre un mouvement
qui revendique le droit au plaisir
et remet en question tous les pouvoirs ?
En fait, que demandaient ces gamins ?
Pas grand chose de sérieux,
peut-être, prendre le pouvoir
à la place de ceux qui l'avaient.
Je crois que s'exprimait
surtout un besoin de démocratie
plus directe et plus proche.
L'opinion publique
soutient la révolte étudiante.
À partir du 10 mai,
le climat devient insurrectionnel.
Le 11 mai au petit matin,
le Quartier latin est
le théâtre d'affrontements violents.
L'homme des tempêtes n'est pas
à l'aise dans ce contexte inédit.
Il prône la fermeté.
Pompidou, lui, veut tendre la main
aux étudiants et privilégie le dialogue.
Après un rendez-vous
houleux avec le général,
il décide,
le 11 mai au soir, de rouvrir la Sorbonne.
"J'ai fait la preuve
de ma volonté d'apaisement."
"J'ai rendu l'université,
à ses maîtres et à ses étudiants."
"Je leur ai tendu la main
pour la concertation la plus large"
"et la plus constructive."
"J'ai libéré les manifestants arrêtés."
"J'ai annoncé une amnistie totale."
Au sommet de l'État,
le conflit entre De Gaulle
et Pompidou est désormais visible.
Après un court voyage en Roumanie,
De Gaulle prononce
une nouvelle allocution
et propose un référendum
sur la rénovation du pays,
insistant notamment sur la participation.
"Françaises, français,"
"au mois de juin,"
"vous vous prononcerez par un vote."
"Au cas où votre réponse serait non,"
"il va de soi que je n'assumerai pas,
ma fonction plus longtemps."
Cette prise de parole
ne calme pas les manifestants.
De Gaulle a 77 ans,
il est fatigué.
Son gouvernement et sa majorité doutent.
L'une des causes de l'ampleur
du mouvement social est le retard
sur les bas salaires.
Le 27 mai,
les conclusions
des négociations de Grenelle,
entre patronats et syndicats,
menées par Pompidou et qui
prévoient notamment une hausse de 35 %
du salaire minimum,
sont rejetées par la base.
Yvonne de Gaulle
se fait prendre à partie dans la rue.
Le matin du 29 mai,
De Gaulle,
qui ne cache pas son pessimisme,
quitte secrètement l'Élysée.
Pendant plusieurs heures,
l'hélicoptère qui
le transporte n'est plus localisé.
Le président a disparu.
Le Premier ministre
lui-même ignore sa destination.
Avant de partir,
le général lui a téléphoné pour
lui faire part de son besoin d'éloignement
et a conclu :
"Je suis vieux, vous êtes jeune,"
"c'est vous qui êtes l'avenir."
"Au revoir, je vous embrasse."
Finalement, de Gaulle arrive
à Baden-Baden chez le général Massu,
commandant des forces
françaises en Allemagne.
Cette disparition a créé un choc,
et le lendemain, le discours
qu'il a choisi de prononcer à la radio,
comme en 1940,
achève de retourner l'opinion.
"Si cette situation
de force se maintient,"
"je devrais,
pour maintenir la République,"
"prendre, conformément à la Constitution,"
"d'autres voies que
le scrutin immédiat du pays."
Aussitôt, une impressionnante
manifestation de soutien déferle
sur les Champs-Élysées.
En moins d'une heure,
un million de personnes s'y retrouvent.
Le 30 mai,
De Gaule a rétabli la situation.
Mais quelques jours plus tard,
il reconnaît que lors
de son voyage à Baden-Baden,
il a envisagé un départ.
"Oui, le 29 mai,"
"j'ai eu la tentation de me retirer."
"Et puis, en même temps,
j'ai pensé que si je partais,"
"la subversion menaçante allait déferler,"
"et emporter la République."
Suivent alors toutes
une série confidences.
"Vous le savez depuis
quelque chose, comme 30 ans,"
"que j'ai à faire à l'histoire"
"il m'est arrivé
quelquefois de me demander"
"si je ne devais pas la quitter."
"Ce fut le cas par exemple,"
"en septembre 1940."
"Après Dakar."
"Ce fut le cas,"
"à Londres en mars 1942."
"Je suis allé dans
un coin de la campagne anglaise,"
"en faisant savoir à Londres,"
"que je ne poursuivrai pas mon entreprise"
"aux côtés de la Grande-Bretagne,"
"si mes conditions
n'étaient pas acceptées."
"Ce fut le cas en 1946."
"Et quand, submergés
par le torrent stérile"
"des partis sur lequel
je n'avais pas prise,"
"et ne pouvant plus
agir à la place où j'étais,"
"je l'ai quitté."
Ces aveux soulignent
une des réactions fréquentes du général,
la tentation du départ.
"Ce fut le cas en 1954,"
"quand je voyais
le rassemblement que j'avais formé,"
"qui était en train de se disloquer."
"Ce fut le cas,"
"le soir du premier tour
de l'élection présidentielle,"
"où une vague de tristesse,"
"a failli m'entrainer au loin."
Pendant cette crise de 1968,
il a été obligé
de repousser son projet de référendum.
"Après avoir procédé aux consultations,"
L'Assemblée nationale est dissoute.
"J'ai prononcé
la dissolution de l'Assemblée nationale."
"Veuillez croire
Monsieur le Président, et cetera."
"Signé Charles de Gaulle."
Les 23 et 30 juin 1968,
les élections législatives
sont un raz de marée en faveur
de la majorité sortante.
Le général sait cependant que cette
victoire n'est pas totalement la sienne.
Pompidou y a pris une grande part.
De Gaulle aurait dit à Claude Pompidou,
"Il paraît
que votre mari a gagné les élections".
La mésentente éclate.
Pompidou quitte Matignon.
Un diplomate,
Maurice Couve de Murville,
ancien ministre
des Affaires étrangères, le remplace.
En le nommant,
De Gaulle veut faire passer un message.
Il reprend la main.
Il s'obstine
à organiser un référendum.
Il décide que le vote
aura lieu au printemps 1969.
Cependant, il se heurte
à des difficultés imprévues.
La brutale hausse des salaires
et le ralentissement de l'économie
ont provoqué une dégradation
de la situation financière du pays.
Le franc est attaqué.
La spéculation fait rage.
Début 1969,
Pompidou dévoile
publiquement ses ambitions.
À Rome, puis à Genève,
il évoque ouvertement
la succession du général.
"Mais je ne crois pas avoir ce
qu'on appelle un avenir politique."
"J'ai un passé politique."
"J'aurais, peut-être,
si Dieu le veut, un destin national."
"Mais c'est autre chose."
"Le problème de la succession est posé."
"Est-ce que vous acceptez cette formule ?"
"Non. Je ne l'accepte pas."
"J'ai dit, le premier même,
que le général de Gaulle"
"est à l'Elysée"
"et que son mandat expire en 1972."
"Il n'y a donc pas
de problème de succession."
"Ceci étant dit, il y aura bien un jour,"
"une élection à la présidence
de la République."
Le divorce entre les deux
hommes est consommé.
À Quimper, le 2 février,
De Gaulle annonce le référendum.
Son ultime combat.
"Comme cette profonde
réforme concerne l'organisation"
"de nos pouvoirs publics
dans tous les domaines,"
"y compris
celui de la Constitution,"
"nous devons
soumettre le projet au peuple,"
"qui, par la voie du référendum,"
"en décidera souverainement."
"Et puisqu'il s'agit d'ouvrir la voie"
"à une espérance nouvelle,"
"nous le ferons au printemps."
Dès le départ,
le pari semble mal engagé.
Le texte soumis
aux Français est long et complexe.
De Gaulle leur propose
de réformer le Sénat
et de décentraliser
les pouvoirs vers les régions.
"Tout le monde s'en fiche",
confie-t-il au général Lalande,
chef de son état major.
À l'approche de la consultation,
les défections
se multiplient dans le camp du oui.
Les sondages
annoncent la victoire du non.
De Gaulle ne lâche pas.
Il espère
qu'un an après la révolte de mai,
son lien direct
avec les Français sera retissé.
Mais il prévoit la défaite,
peut-être avec soulagement.
Le vendredi 25 avril dans la matinée,
il enregistre
son ultime appel télévisé.
"Votre réponse"
"va engager le destin de la France."
"Parce que"
"si je suis désavoué"
"par une majorité d'entre vous,"
"ma tâche actuelle de chef de l'État
deviendra, évidemment, impossible."
"Et je cesserai aussitôt"
"d'exercer mes fonctions."
"Jamais la décision"
"de chacune et de chacun de vous"
"n'aura pesé aussi lourd."
"Vive la République !"
"Vive la France !"
Le président quitte ensuite l'Elysée.
Le 27 avril, le général
et madame de Gaulle votent à Colombey.
Ils s'enferment
ensuite à La Boisserie.
À 20 heures, le succès des non
paraît assuré en métropole.
En effet, le non l'emporte
avec 52,4 % des suffrages exprimés.
Le président prend acte
immédiatement du refus.
À 00h10,
il publie un communiqué.
"Je cesse d'exercer mes
fonctions de président de la République."
"Cette décision prend
effet aujourd'hui à midi."
Pour la première fois depuis 1958,
De Gaulle est battu.
François Mauriac qualifie
le référendum et le départ du général
de "cas sans précédent
de suicide en plein bonheur.
Mais certains supposent
que le président
savait que, vainqueur ou battu,
il en sortirait encore grandi.
Dès l'annonce
de sa démission,
le général
se cloître à La Boisserie.
Ma vie politique était terminée.
Yvonne m'a dit
que j'avais fait pour les Français,
beaucoup plus
qu'ils ne méritent.
Ils sont ingouvernables,
divisés, individualistes à l'extrême.
Maintenant, ici, à Colombey,
je dois continuer à écrire.
Il fait savoir à Pompidou
que s'il approuve sa candidature,
il n'interviendra
pas dans la campagne.
Au début, ses rares
interlocuteurs le trouvent maussade.
La défaite a marqué le général.
Il entreprend
la rédaction de ses Mémoires d'espoir.
Il y trouve un apaisement.
Le 10 mai, Charles et Yvonne de Gaulle
s'envolent pour un long séjour en Irlande.
Le général ne souhaite pas
être en France le 18 juin.
Il a des ancêtres irlandais.
C'est une terre qu'il affectionne.
Les paysages tourmentés du Connemara
sont en harmonie avec ses états d'âme.
À Dublin, De Gaulle est reçu
par le président Eamon de Valera,
héros de la guerre d'indépendance.
Lors du dîner,
le général remercie son hôte.
"En ce moment
grave de ma longue vie,"
"j'ai trouvé ici
ce que je cherchais,"
"être en face de moi-même."
Le 18 juin,
le général déjeune
à l'ambassade de France.
Sur le livre d'or,
il écrit cet aphorisme de Nietzsche
"Rien ne vaut rien, il ne se passe
jamais rien et cependant tout arrive."
"Mais cela est indifférent."
De retour d'Irlande,
le général ne quitte pas La Boisserie.
Toujours pas de visiteurs
politiques, à l'exception de Malraux.
L'écrivain l'interroge
"Pourquoi êtes-vous parti sur une question
aussi secondaire que celle des régions ?"
"À cause de l'absurdité."
Le général fixe
Malraux du regard et répète
"à cause de l'absurdité."
L'homme de conviction est étrangement
pénétré par cette question existentielle.
Il se consacre
à la rédaction de ses mémoires.
Il peine, se bat avec les mots,
recherche
interminablement l'expression juste.
Le temps est compté.
La course de la mémoire contre la mort.
À l'approche du 18 juin 1970,
le général part en Espagne.
Il rencontre Franco, le vieux dictateur.
La scène fait couler beaucoup d'encre.
Malraux et Mauriac s'avouent choqués.
À l'automne,
le premier tome
de ses Mémoires d'espoir paraît.
Des mémoires
en forme de testament politique.
Le succès est foudroyant.
Le général se remet au travail
avec une ardeur redoublée.
Il y passe ses journées entières.
Le lundi 9 novembre,
De Gaulle travaille
comme d'habitude toute la matinée
avant de se
promener dans le parc.
Le froid est arrivé.
L'automne est rude.
Vers 18 h 45,
il quitte son bureau,
s'installe dans la bibliothèque,
devant une table de bridge.
Comme il en a l'habitude,
il entame une réussite
en attendant le dîner.
Soudain,
peu avant 19 heures,
il pousse un cri de douleur
et s'écroule sans connaissance.
Une rupture d'anévrisme
vient d'emporter Charles de Gaulle.
Le décès est tenu
secret jusqu'au lendemain matin.
"Françaises, Français."
"Le général de Gaulle est mort."
"La France est veuve."
La disparition du général
suscite une émotion planétaire.
Son testament est publié.
Il refuse des obsèques nationales.
Une cérémonie très
simple doit avoir lieu à Colombey.
Le 12 novembre,
la foule est dense
et le silence impressionnant
quand le cercueil de l'homme du 18 juin
sort de La Boisserie sur un engin blindé.
Après la cérémonie religieuse,
De Gaulle est porté en terre
aux côtés de sa fille Anne.
À Paris, au même moment,
a lieu à Notre-Dame,
une cérémonie religieuse très solennelle.
Le monde entier est présent
pour rendre hommage au chef de guerre
et au président disparu.
"Les Français devaient croire
que je n'aimais que le son du canon"
"et les marches militaires,"
"non."
"J'aimais la musique fluide de Debussy."
Yvonne de Gaulle,
après la mort du général,
se retira discrètement
dans la maison de retraite
des sœurs
de l'Immaculée Conception.
Elle mourut
neuf ans après son mari.
Elle repose désormais aux côtés
de Charles de Gaulle et de sa fille Anne,
dans le cimetière de Colombey.